muy bien Vamos a continuar con más temas
y es posible que nunca se resuelva el
debate sobre Quién es el mejor jugador
de la historia en la NBA en todos los
tiempos sin embargo algunos o podrían
conceder ese título a Lebron James y es
que bueno este nombre ha sonado mucho
esta semana después de romper uno de los
récords más sagrados del deporte Y es
que el alero de Los Ángeles Lakers
superó el registro de su antecesor casi
de casi 40 años que lo mantuvo carisma
Future schavar como el máximo anotador
de la NBA Así que vamos a conversar
sobre este tema con Álvaro Martínez
quien es comentarista de la NBA y de la
NFL es creador de contenidos digitales a
través de ritmo NBA y ritmo NFL para la
que también por cierto cubre el Super
Bowl en Phoenix y bien bienvenido señor
Martín y también nos acompaña nuestro
periodista de deportes Luis Méndez
Muchísimas gracias Ángela y saludos para
Álvaro bienvenido tenerte acá en Francia
24 y hablar un poquito yo ya sabemos del
récord de Lebron jamese en cuanto a la
mayor cantidad de puntos en la NBA Pero
qué otras estadísticas estarían
colocando Lebron James como ese gran
jugador de todos los tiempos
es el jugador más completo que ha jugado
en la NBA y es un jugador que puede
marcar todo tipo de estadística
importante
comenzando con puntos pero por ejemplo
para darles un ejemplo ya está cuarto en
la lista de asistencias eso es un logro
tremendo algo por ejemplo que Michael
Jordan nunca estuvo remotamente cerca de
de arañar el otro gran jugador previo
que sea por los dos jugadores previos
que se hablan son por ejemplo de la
primera época de la NBA en los años
sesentas y Caribe que fue precisamente
la figura que acaba de eclipsar en
cuanto a puntos Lebron James pero Lebron
James tiene esa característica de ser un
jugador completo en una época donde la
preparación el estudio el análisis del
juego Creo que fomentaba muchísima más
paridad En otras palabras era mucho más
difícil ganar campeonatos y mucho más
difícil destacarte del resto de los
otros 450 de la liga en cada temporada y
siempre muy odioso muy difícil y
prácticamente imposible comparar épocas
las condiciones no son las mismas pero
creo que hay que señalar el entorno de
cada época para poner a cada jugador en
contexto Así que creo que en este
momento y cuando termine su carrera
Lebron James y creo que podría seguir
jugando dos tres cuatro años más Te
puedes ir con gran dignidad ese lugar
más completo que ha visto la liga en
todos los aspectos si no menciono
tampoco el tema defensivo donde también
se ha destacado por gran parte de su
carrera si es el mejor de todos los
tiempos Yo creo que es una cuestión muy
subjetiva y quien vio cierta época
quizás pueda hacer una comparación por
ejemplo Yo viví el legado de Jordan que
hoy vi el la carrera entera de Lebron
Jane a mí me parece que Jordan en su
época fue un tan dominante que me parece
que en mi opinión quizás sea el jugador
que se ha designado con esa ese ese
honor y ese Laurel pero por ejemplo yo
no vi jugar
he visto cosas que ha hecho Bill Ross y
quizás de haber visto Bill rosson
pensaría que sería Russell Así que eso
es muy subjetivo pero sin duda Lebron
James es el jugador más completo que ha
visto esta liga y además la suerte de
ser un jugador muy longevo que es el
otro elemento solamente Karim abdultamar
te compara LeBron ese aspecto y por eso
estamos viendo esto por último Luis
antes de que termine la carrera de
Lebron James veremos a Lebron James unas
estadísticas vitalicias que te van a
deslumbrar y quizás el nuevo estandarte
quizás en las marcas que digan bueno esa
marca nadie la va a quebrar en el futuro
que la estableció Lebron James a través
de más de Álvaro usted habla de un
Lebron James que es una figura muy
longeva en el deporte acercándose a sus
40 años está en condiciones físicas
óptimas y acaba de romper un gran récord
A qué se debe esta gran en longevidad
que usted menciona esta este gran
mantenimiento de su estado físico y
emocional
Bueno este chico ama el básquet y digo
chico todavía pero no debería decirlo ya
es un ya es que está en camino a ser
abuelo pero algo que él siempre ha
tenido es un cuerpo perfecto y llegó a
la liga con dieciocho años de edad con
un cuerpo de adulto y jugó ciertas
posiciones al avanzar su carrera se ha
ido deslizando quizás de un jugador que
jugaba la posición de esporta hacer un
jugador que juega la posición o sea de
externo a interno en todo ese proceso
adoptó su cuerpo para la exigencia del
papel que tenía que fungir en el equipo
y por último ya llevado años escuchando
él gasta más de un millón de dólares el
cálculo ahora es John y medio de dólares
en todo lo que sea alimentación
nutrición masaje
pliométricas todo tipo de tecnología
para él recuperarse para él estar en
posición óptima de física óptima y poder
producir al más alto nivel pero creo que
todo eso te habla y se dice e impresiona
pero yo creo que el elemento más
importante Lebron James es su cerebro es
un jugador que piensa muy bien el juego
es un gran cazador lo que le favorece a
él es hijo él puede ver cosas el resto
de los jugadores en la cancha no pueden
ver en ese momento la puedan anticipar
yo creo que quizás la clave y el órgano
más importante Lebron James no sea su
físico está su cerebro ahora Álvaro
mencionaste que Lebron James está
próximo o va a futuro a ser abuelo tiene
una linda familia y uno de sus hijos
bronnie ha mostrado LeBron intención de
jugar con él al tiempo en el tabloncillo
Qué posibilidades hay de que esto se
logre sabemos que brownie si acaso puede
estar en el Draft de 2024
bueno broni se perfilaba como una figura
que quizás de haber sido seleccionado en
ese sorteo en el Draft de la NBA de
jugadores ingresan en la liga podría ser
seleccionado en la segunda de solamente
dos puertas en cada sorteo o sea era un
jugador que no se perfilaba como un
jugador top un jugador de primer nivel
sin embargo El chico ha dado mucho ha
mejorado muchísimo en el último año
obviamente ha tenido la ayuda de su
padre preparando para que entienda el
deporte obviamente ha tenido gran fogueo
gran roce contemporáneos a un muy buen
nivel Así que la expectativa Es que este
chico va a poder jugar en la liga no va
a desentonar en la lista en un momento
Lebron James dijo que él cuando
terminase el contrato actual con el
equipo de Los Ángeles tu próximo
contrato dependería del equipo que
fichase a su hijo o sea me iría a la
ciudad del equipo que fichase a bronnie
Y eso sería muy interesante pero creo
que lo que va a pasar imagino es que si
ningún equipo NBA ficha a prony en el
sorteo el equipo de
en ese momento sería la ley de los
Ángeles lo fiche como agente libre
cuatro y lo invita al campamento
entrenamiento y de ahí veremos un equipo
de NBA tiene quince jugadores algunos de
ellos son jugadores marginales que ven
muy cancha por lo tanto es un jugador de
desarrollo no veo Por qué un equipo NBA
no podría ser lo propio con Rony James
bien ahora con recorto sin recorto ya
llegando al final de esta entrevista
Álvaro Lo cierto es que podemos decir
que Lebron James es una de estas figuras
que llegan a la historia del deporte y
lo cambian lo transforman en algo más
hablemos de eso
sin duda Lebron James desde que era un
chico era un prodigio le decían el
escogido era su apodo cuando estaba en
la escuela secundaria de Saint Vincent
marries en acro y quizás eso fue un
engendro y una creación de su momento
del de La era de las redes sociales una
era por ejemplo que no vivió en gran
parte Michael Jordan o en su totalidad
de su carrera Así que yo creo que eres
también un engendro de suera en cuanto a
su figura su presencia y su legado todo
lo que ha hecho ha sido cronometrado es
cerca ayer en la ceremonia donde los
Ángeles celebró el quiebre de su barca
en una un partido en el cual jugó su
equipo pero él no porque descansó
te das cuenta el trayecto tan enorme es
recorrido un chico que nació
sin padre en una situación económica y
social muy complicada este chico pudo
mantener su enfoque puedo mantener tu
alma más bien pura
enfocado en el baloncesto le permitió
ascender social y económicamente y
deportivamente al puesto que está esa
historia
es tan importante y tan atractiva como
lo que hacen cancha LeBron está Lebron
James jugador y celebro James figura y
lo que estamos viendo ahora es la
transición en su vida y carrera el
deportista a la figura No sabemos
exactamente dónde va a terminar esa
figura pero hasta ahora es una historia
prácticamente un cuento de hadas